the big news out of bachelor nation
today season 25 will feature the first
ever black bachelor lauren zima has all
the details that's right Ted his name is
Matt James and he's actually not a total
stranger to fans of the franchise and
matt is speaking out today about this
game-changing moment in bachelor history
we can't have change until you put that
first foot forward in that first foot
forward for The Bachelor franchise is
having a black lead so I'm excited to
take on that role
we're told today's announcement has been
in the works for a while but the
definitive decision to cast Matt was
made in the last few weeks it's an honor
you know I'm just gonna lean into myself
and how my mom raised me and hopefully
when people invite me into their home's
on Monday night they're gonna see that
I'm not much different from them and
they see that diverse love stories are
beautiful so just who is Matt James well
the 28 year old is Bachelorette alum
Tyler cameras best friend Tyler
revealing his roommate was pantsless for
his interview on GMA the two played
college football together they work
together and they tick talked their way
through quarantine I think Matt is an
incredible person and quite a catch Matt
could put a smile on anyone's face just
five days ago the two were at a protest
fighting racial inequality in Miami
Matt was supposed to be a contestant on
Claire Crawley's upcoming Bachelorette
season we spoke with him in March before
filming was halted its long-awaited is
it long-awaited did you want to go on
the show for a while
Tyler's mom actually recommended that I
go on and she nominated me anything that
you're afraid of in all that you know
you're afraid to get your heart broken
we've all been there and when you're
vulnerable when you put yourself out
there like that you've got to be ready
for that to happen so we'll see how it
goes
The Bachelor franchise has long been
called out for its lack of diversity we
just talked to Rachel Lindsay the only
black lead ever who said she was just
fed up with the lack of changes I don't
want to be affiliated with a franchise
who's not on the right side of this at
this time at this point you can't be
neutral you're either on the wrong side
or the right side and the franchise to
me has been on the wrong side for 18
years definitely we need to see a lead
of color in the role for season 25 I
said that last year after Mike Johnson
was not cast a lot of people are excited
about the idea of you potentially being
the first black bachelor I'll be the
first black badge lobby the first
bachelor that's a veteran I'll be the
first Mike Johnson so yeah it's more
than just me in the first place actually
after this morning's announcement
Rachel appeared on The Bachelor Party
podcast and she wasn't exactly happy
with the news it's a band-aid it's the
easiest thing to me that you could do
and I hate that it is in response or it
seems like it's a knee-jerk reaction and
in response to what happened in our
society what happened with George Floyd
and the pressure that you're getting
from society it's almost like a man had
to die in such a gruesome and public way
for us to get a black bastard she even
called out Matt specifically before the
bachelor news became official we don't
even know you
so I entered the only reason people are
intimate James is because people are
into Thailand we don't know anything
about my Matt James other than the fact
that he's affiliated with Tyler so I
can't say I'm sold on him cuz I know
nothing about him I've seen the
Instagram story you and Tyler
good-looking guys you're fit guys why do
you want to walk away from like an
awesome partying life in New York City
the guy in his 20s and then go on this
shower are you really ready to get
married it's really fruitless there's
not a lot of meaning in that stuff and
I'm looking for something meaningful
pretty good answer
just saying okay so Matt's season will
still air after the new season of The
Bachelorette Clare Crawley's journey for
love debuts in the fall
[Music]